ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนิคสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนครับ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สายโอเครุ่น
สบายดีค่ะครูนิคสบายดีนะคะสบายดีครับคน
นี้ดีค่ะแล้ววันนี้วันอะไรคะครูนิวันนี้
วันพุธครับ
นี้เขียนผู้หญิงช่วยเขียนหน่อยเพราะคุณ
เล็กปากกายังไม่ดีอะไรจ๊ะวันนี้
วันนี้วันพุธนะคะจะเขียนยากนิดหน่อยนะคะ
โอเคครับวันที่เท่าไหร่คะครูนิคพูดวันที่
เท่าไหร่วันที่ 25 ครับค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
อาภาคมครับ
ปีพตอะไรคะดีผช
2565 ขับ
ปีคศอะไรคะอีกคศ 2
022 ขับค่ะแล้วตอนนี้ที่บ้านครูนิคเวลา
กี่โมงคะโอเคที่บ้านคุณนิคตอนนี้ครับ
8:00 น
38 นาทีตอนเช้านะครับตอนเช้า
จะกลางวันเนาะกะเช้านะคะชายแล้ว
บ้านครูหญิงตอนนี้กี่โมงครับขอที่บ้านครู
หญิงตอนนี้
8:00 น
38 นาทีค่ะ
ตอนก็ของปิ้งมีทรายเป็นตอนกลางคืนนะกลาง
คืนแล้วกินกำลังจะนอนนะคะคุณอีกแหละเพิ่ง
ตื่นๆแล้วก็กำลังจะไปทำงานๆใช่จำเราจะไป
ทำงานจริงๆตอนนี้ก็คือทำงานอยู่
เริ่มทำงานแล้ว
แต่ผู้หญิงเนี้ยทำงานอันนี้ก็คือทำงาน
เสร็จนะฮะก็
เพิ่ม
ใช่ๆคุณจะเล่าให้ฟังว่าอาทิตย์ที่แล้วครู
นิคเนี่ยไปไปเที่ยวหมาจะพูดว่าไปที่สุด
ใช่ก็ออกไปไหนน้อไปงานครับมีงานเช้างาน
อะไรหรอคะครูเด็กเขาเรียกว่าเป็นงานการ
กุศลครับ
งานการกุศลก็คือเดี๋ยวคุณนี้จะเอารูปให้
ดู
อันนี้รูปภาพในงานผู้หญิงใช่มีคนมาเยอะๆ
ขาวก็มีคนหลายคนเลยมาครับเพราะว่างานอัน
นี้เนี่ยเพื่อนของแฟนคูนิสเนี่ยเขาจัดงาน
เป็นงานการกุศลก็คือก็จะให้คนหลายๆคนไหน
มาแล้วก็ก็บริจาคเอาเงินให้กับของที่เป็น
คนจัดงานแล้วเขาก็จะเอาเงินทั้งหมดเนี่ย
ไปให้กับเอ่อองค์กรหรือให้กับคนที่
ต้องการใช้เงินนี้ขาดอ๋ออ๋อเหมือนเหมือน
จัดงานเอาเงินไปช่วยคนอื่นใช่ไหมคะถ้าครู
นิคอยากไปพรุ่งนี้ก็เอาเงินไปช่วยก็คล้าย
ๆแบบทำบุญอันไหนเราก็จะเรียกว่ามันเป็น
การกุศลเพราะว่าเราเอาเงินแม่ไปช่วยคน
อื่นช่วยค่า G ถ้ามีปัญหาก็มันก็มีหลาย
อย่างครับอันนี้ของเอ่องานอันนี้ที่คนนี้
ไปเนี่ยเขาจะเป็นงานสำหรับคนที่
คนที่เหมือนกับดื่มแอลกอฮอล์เยอะแล้วเขา
ติด
ชายคนนะครับเขาก็จะต้องมันไปหาคนช่วย
เหมือนเป็นนักมันเป็นจิตแพทย์นักพร้อม
วิทยาไปคุยเราก็เลิกดื่มเหล้าดื่ม
แอลกอฮอล์เพราะเหมือนเป็นโรงพยาบาลเนี่ย
หรอคะจริงพยาบาลจึงก็ไม่ใช่ไม่เหมือนโรง
พยาบาลแต่เขาจะเป็นเหมือนเป็นองค์กรเป็น
ออฟฟิศที่มีคนจัดงานที่ว่าเหมือนในหนังนะ
ครับที่มีห้อง 1 ห้องแล้วก็มีเก้าอี้วง
กลมแล้วเขาก็จะนานแล้วก็คุยว่าผมชื่อนี้
ผมแม่ติดเหล้าผมตอนนี้ผมไม่ดื่มเหล้ามา 2
อาทิตย์แล้วแต่แบบนี้เขาก็นี้ก็คุณหมอใช่
ไหมแล้วก็จะมีคนที่แบบอยากจะเลิกขาอยากจะ
เลิกก็ไปนั่งคุยงานของครูนิคก็เอาเงินไป
ช่วยคนตรงนี้ใช่ไหมหาคนตรงนี้
เพราะว่ามันพรุ่งนี้ไปมาไปมาชาย
ครับก็ก็เหมือนกับไอ้ที่เมื่อกี้อ่ะครับ
ที่ว่าคนเขาไปหาหมอแบบนี้ที่ไปคุยที่นั่ง
กันหลายๆคนเนี่ยมันต้องเสียเงินแล้วบางคน
น่ะเขาไม่มีเงินเพื่อจะไปคุยแบบนั้น
ชายอันนี้มันก็งานนี้ก็เหมือนเอาเงินไป
ช่วยเขาๆใช่ครับดีแล้วคะ
คุณนี่ก็ไปแล้วอ่ะ
พี่ก็ไปงานนี้กับแฟนคุณนิแล้วก็ก็พ่อแม่
แสนคุณนิดครับค่ะอะไรแล้วทำอะไรบ้างอ่ะคะ
เวลาไปไปในงานแล้วก็ไปงานครับเขาก็เขาก็
จะถามชื่อเพราะว่าคนจะต้องซื้อตั๋ว
ค่ะงานก่อนชายของน้ำดูชื่อเหมือนเป็นราย
ชื่อ ABC แบบนี้ครับแต่คุณนิจะซื้อตั๋ว
กี่บาทคะแนะคุณนิกะห์ไม่รู้เพราะแกนคุณ
นี้ก็ซื้อ
นี้ก็จะเป็นแบบดอลลาร์และกันนะคงไม่ใช่
เงินไทยนะไม่ต้องซื้อตั๋วก่อนเพราะว่า
เงินที่เราซื้อตั๋วก็เอาไปช่วยคนชายต้อง
ทุกอย่างที่เราจ่ายเงินเนี่ยเงินก็คือเอา
ไปช่วยคนพวกนี้ครับคนที่มีปัญหาขับชาย
เกี่ยวกับเพียงดื่มแอลกอฮอล์ข้าวเขาก็ก็
เขาก็ถามชื่อครับแล้วพอได้ชื่อเขาก็จะให้
เบอร์มา
ๆๆเขาก็จะให้เบอร์มาเหมือนกับของคู่นี้ไป
แล้วเขาก็จะให้เบอร์
100 อันนี้อาอะไรก็หรือแบบนี้
นั่นแหละแบบนั้นถูกแล้วหนึ่งก็จะมาใส่
100  100 แล้วก็เพราะว่าหนึ่งงานครับเขา
ก็จะมีเหมือนกับใครที่เขาจะมีหลายอย่าง
มากเกี่ยวกับการกุศลว่าสมมติเขาจะบอกว่า
โอเคใครสนใจที่จะช่วยเงิน 500 ดอนฆ่าร้อย
บาท US ดอลลาร์ให้เอง
อ๋อแล้วทีเนี้ยคนที่ยกเลิกก็จะมือกับ
เบอร์ที่เขามีอ่ะก็ขอคือเบอร์คือเหมือน
ตัวเราไม่ใช่เพราะเขาเห็นตัวเลขนะครับก็
จะมีคนและเห็นดูแล้วก็โอเคเบอร์นี้บริจาค
เงินเท่านี้ครับค่ะ
เพราะมันมีหลายคนถ้าจะจำชื่อทุกคนเนี่ย
ไม่ได้ให้เธอก็ให้ทุกคนเหมือนมีมีกระดาษ
แล้วก็เป็นเบอร์ของตัวเองแล้วก็ยก
ชายยกเอาชายถ้าเป็นไงก็เป็นแบบนี้ก็มันก็
น่าสนใจดีทีนี้เนี่ยมันจะมีอีกอันหนึ่ง
ที่คุณนิดคุณนิดชอบมันก็คือจับฉลากอะไร
อ่ะเจ้าฉลาดยังไงเหรอคะคุณเอ็กซ์มันจะ
เป็นแบบนี้ครับ
เนี่ยก็ตื่นในงานเขาก็จะมีโต๊ะโต๊ะเราใน
โต๊ะเนี่ยมันก็จะมีของหลายอันอันนี้ใช่
ไหมคะทั้งหมดนี้คือของๆของแล้วเขาก็จะมี
นะครับมันก็เป็นกระป๋องอ่ะที่มีเบอร์ 1
เบอร์ 2 เบอร์ 3 เบอร์ 4
เบอร์ 1 เบอร์ 2 แล้วกระป๋องตรงนี้ทำอะไร
หรอคะคือเด็กมันคืออะไรก็ป้องอันนี้ครับ
ก็ก็คือ
ถ้าคนที่อยากได้ของวันนี้นะก็คือจะต้องไป
ซื้อตั๋ว
ตั๋วนี้ครับจะ 1 ใบเนี่ยตัวหนึ่งใบห้า
ดอลลาร์สหรัฐ 5 เหรียญใช่ไหมค่ะเหรียญเรา
ก็จะซื้อกี่ตัวกี่ใบก็ได้ค่ะค่ะอยากได้
มากๆก็ซื้อเยอะๆให้พอซื้อเสร็จครับก็มา
เขียนเบอร์ของตัวเองสมมติเนี่ยอ้าอาจจะมี
เบอร์คุณนี่คือเบอร์ 100 คูณนี่ก็ได้นะ
เธอ 100 เราก็ผับค่ะเพราะขับแล้วทำยังนะ
ครับแบบนี้ครับก็เอาใส่ในเอเชียที่เป็น
กระปุกเว้ใช่อ๋อ
แต่ว่าถ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยใส่แค่กล่องเบอร์
หนึ่งครับเบอร์เดียวก็ได้ก็ได้แล้วก็จะ
ใส่เบอร์ 1
10 ใบก็ได้ครับหรือว่าจะใส่เบอร์ 1
เบอร์ 2 เบอร์ 3 เบอร์ 4 ไป 5 ใส่ทุก
กล่องก็ได้ๆครับเขาก็ผู้หญิงเห็นแล้วชอบ
อะไรก็เขียนเบอร์ของครูหญิงแล้วก็ใส่เข้า
ไปในของที่อยากได้
[เพลง]
จอได้ครับเงินทุกอย่างก็คือซื้อตั๋วก็เอา
ไปเหมือนเป็นกล้วยใช่ใช่ครับ
อันนี้คุณนี้ก็ชอบชอบเล่นวันนี้คุณ x ใส่
เบอร์อะไรคะกูนิสัยอีดอกเบอร์อะไรฉันตั๋ว
ตั๋วตั๋วของครูนิคอันนี้หน้ากระดาษคนนี้
นะใช่คุณนิก้าใส่ใส่เบอร์ 10 มันไม่มีใน
รูปว่าโอเคนะได้เพราะว่าหนึ่งงาน
ที่คุณนิดอยากได้ถ่ายรูปอันอื่นแต่ไม่
ถ่ายรูปเบอร์ที่อยากได้
เพราะว่ามันมีเยอะมากคุยเออในงานครับมี
ทั้งหมด 25 เบิกก็คือไอ้กล่องอันนี้ใช่
ไหมคะคุณเอ็กซ์ปีตั้งแต่เบอร์ 1 ถึงเบอร์
25 ใช่ใช่วันนี้ก็ใส่ไปของที่คุณนึกอยาก
ได้เนี่ยจริงๆก็ไม่ได้เป็นของที่คุณนึก
อยากได้นะคืออ้าวงงมั้ย
คือว่าคุณนี้เห็นของอันนี้แล้วคุณนี้
แกรู้ว่าลุงของคุณอิ๊กที่อยู่ที่อเมริกา
มีแต่เขาชอบอ๋ออ๋อ
เล้ยถ้าเกิดว่าเราลองเอาเบอร์ใส่เราได้
เนี่ยเอาไปเอาไปเซอร์ไพรส์ลุง
ใจไงตัวนี้ก็เลยลองดูมันเป็นเหมือนลูก
ฟุตบอลนะครับแล้วมันมีมาเป็นของนักฟุตบอล
ในทีมนัดคนเป็นเป็นฟุตบอลแบบฟุตบอลแบบ 11
คนใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่อเมริกันฟุตบอลอเมริกัน
ฟุตบอลใช่อ่าเป็นคุยก็ไม่รู้ว่าลูก
อเมริกันฟุตบอลไปยังไงมันก็เหมือนลูก
รักบี้อ่ะครับคนไทย X ใช่ไหมคะคุณเด็กอ่ะ
แล้วก็มีลายเซ็นมีลายเซ็นผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้
ว่าเขาชื่ออะไรวะไม่ทันนักอเมริกันฟุตบอล
มีลายเซ็นมีทั้งทีมเลยครับ
น่ะคนนี้ก็เขียนเบอร์ตัวเองไปเราก็ใส่คะ
ค่ะแล้วก็คือนี้
ครูนิคใส่ใบกี่ไบต์ตั๋วเนี่ยคุณนิก้าใส่
ไป
หนึ่ง
120 ใบใช่
ใส่เบอร์เดียวเลยใช่ไหมคะคุณนิสัยลงไปใน
เบอร์ 10 ใช่ใส่ไปเลย 20 ใบในเบอร์ 10
แล้วก็เพราะเขาบอกว่าเขาจะประกาศเขาจะบอก
คนที่ที่ได้รางวัลเนี่ยตอนประมาณ 3 ทุ่ม 3
ทุ่มก็นราที่งานจะปิดค่ะ 9:00 นครับคุณ
อีกนะก็ใส่เบอร์ไปตั้งแต่ 6 โมงเย็นเลย
แล้วก็นั่งรอนักปังกินขนม
แล้วก็รอลุ้นให้เขาจะฉลากเป็นเบอร์ของครู
นิคแล้วทรุดเบอร์ 100 ใช่คุณนี้ก็รอที่
นี้มีแต่พอถึงเวลาคุณก็เอาแล้วเขาเขาบอก
ว่าเขาจะไปจับไปจับสลากคนที่ใส่เบอร์นี้
ว่าจะได้รางวัลเขาก็ไปท้องก็เขาจับละเขา
จะเขียนบนกระดานค่ะมีหลายรังค่ะเขาจะมา
ประกาศมาบอกพูดทีละอันเนี่ยมันช้ามันเสีย
เวลาขออย่างเบอร์หนึ่งเนี่ยมันก็มีรางวัล
รางวัลรางวัลมากกว่า 1 อย่างใช่ไหมคุณนี้
ไม่แต่จริงๆนี้คือก็คือคนที่ใส่เบอร์
หนึ่งก็ได้ทั้งหมดตรงนั้นเลยนะก็ได้ทั้ง
หมดเอ้าเตะทั้งหมดเลยเอาช้อนก็มี 25
รางวัลทำไมก็จะจับมาๆชายใช่ก็น่ะคนนี้ก็
โอเคเขาบอกว่าเขาจะจับแล้วคนนี้ก็นั่งค่ะ
แต่คุณนี้ก็ทำเป็นทำเหมือนไม่ตื่นเต้นนะ
ครับอ่ะ L ผ้าเหมือนแบบได้ก็ได้นะไม่ได้
เหรอโอเคไม่ตื่นเต้นนะเฮ้ออะไรกูนี่เนี่ย
ยืนได้อยากได้ได้
ที่นี้คุณนี้ก็เห็นละเขาอ่ะเขียนเบอร์ว่า
หลังวันนี้เบอร์นี้ได้ก็เอาเบอร์หนึ่ง
มิสเตอร์อะไรอย่างนี้ใช่ไหมคะเบอร์ 2 อ่า
มิสอะไรก็จะเขียนชื่อนี้หรอคะเขาเขาก็จะ
เขียนเบอร์นี้ครับเบอร์ที่เธอฉันไม่ลืมไป
ลืมไปขอโทษค่ะ
ลืมไปว่ามันเป็น Number  Number ครับปู๊ด
เบอร์หนึ่งอ้ะเบอร์ 65
กล่องเบอร์ 2 เบอร์ 80 จะเขียน
คุณนี้ก็รอรอลุ้นแล้วก็เดินไปดูชื่อเดิน
ไปดูเบอร์ตัวเองที่มีด่านมีไหม
มีไหม
ผู้หญิงคิดว่า
มีแล้วกันกูจริงใจดีให้ครูนิได้คุณนิดใส่
เบอร์คุณอี๊ดตั้ง 20 นะเออใช่ 20 ใบอ่ะ
เราก็ต้องหยิบมาจับฉลาดขึ้นมามันก็ต้องมี
ของคุณนิคสิ
แต่มันไม่มี
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
มันไม่มีคนนี้เก่าไม่ได้เธอสิบละ 550 ครู
นิคเนี่ยเบอร์ 100 ก็
ไม่ไม่มีไม่มีครูนี้ก็ไม่ได้เด็กก็ไม่
เป็นไรก็จบทำบุญชายสวยคนแล้วก็ได้รุ่นใช่
ไหมสนุก
คุณครูนิครู้ไหมคะว่าใครได้เบอร์ 10
คุณนี้กับจำไม่ได้ว่าเบอร์อะไรแต่ถ้าจะ
ไม่ผิดถ้าจะไม่ผิดเหมือนจะเป็นเพราะว่ามี
เพื่อนของแสงคุณนิคหลายคนเข้าไป
ผู้หญิงรู้ไปว่าเพื่อนของแฟนคุณนึกเนี่ย
ทุกคนน่ะที่ใส่จับฉลากเนี่ยได้หมดเลยเอา
สุราษฎร์ก็ใส่ได้ในเบอร์ 3 คนนิสัยเวอร์ 3
ก็จะขึ้นมาเป็นหมายเลขของเพื่อนของแฟนครู
นิคใช่แบบนี้คนนี้คนเดียวไม่ได้
แล้วแฟนคลินิกใส่ในเบอร์อะไรไหมคะคุณแตง
คูนิกเนี่ยเขาเขาก็เออใช่เขาก็ใส่เขาก็
ใส่หลายอันนะคะเขาก็ไม่ได้เน็ตไว้ให้มีคน
ไม่ได้เป็นเพื่อน
ก็คือครูนิคและแฟนแต่เพื่อนเพื่อนเพื่อน
เพื่อน
แม่ของแฟนเนี่ยซึ่งคนได้ทุกคนได้ Word
แต่คนหาตัวเล็กเอาให้ว่าเบอร์อะไรที่ได้
ของที่คุณนิดอยากได้
คิดว่าหลายๆคนก็น่าจะอยากได้ของเบอร์
เดียวกับครูนิดนะ
คุณนิคกินก็ตอนแรกเนี่ยคุณนิคอ่ะใส่เบอร์
เข้าไปนั้นเต็มคนแรกๆเลยแล้วมีนิดเดียว
คุณนี้ก็เลยคนใส่ไม่เยอะได้แน่นอนเราใส่
ตั้งจิตเบอร์ 20 ใบ
แต่กูนิคใส่ใส่ตั้งแต่ 6 โมงนะคะเขาจับ
ฉลาก 9:00 นนะคะคุณนี้ขึ้น
สลาก 21:00 นมีเวลาใส่เยอะนะคะคนเลี้ยงก็
คิดไปเองอ่ะ
ถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงคิดว่าคนอเมริกาหลายๆคนก็
อาจจะอยากได้ลูกลูกอาเมริกันฟุตบอลโลก
นั้นด้วยไง
ใช่ตัวนี้ก็ไม่เป็นไรก็สายค่ะเราก็จะคิด
ว่าไม่เป็นไรทำบุญด้วยไหมทำบุญแล้วก็สนุก
ชายๆก็อันนั้นแหละครับก็เป็นเกี่ยวกับ
เรื่องที่คุณนิดไปเมื่ออาทิตย์ที่แล้ว
ครับอาทิตย์เอาที่ไปไงกุศลเรามีฉลากแบบ
นี้
ก็ไม่ได้ก็ไม่เป็นไรนะคะปีหน้า
2023 ปีหน้าเอาใหม่จะต้องเตรียมเงินเยอะ
ๆแล้วแล้วก็หาซื้อตั๋ว
ให้ต้องมากกว่า 20 ใบแล้วพอ 20 ใบเนี่ยก็
ยังไม่ได้
ก็สนามเป็นไก่ใจโกศลที่สนุกค่ะต่ายเขาก็
แต่ก็น่าไปแล้วหน้าไปทำบุญหน้าไปเหลือบ
มันสนุกนะว่าไม่ใช่แบบว่าเออไปแล้วก็น่า
เบื่อมันดูสนุกแล้วก็ตื่นเต้นด้วยเฮ้ยของ
บางอย่างและผู้หญิงเหมือนกับอ่าคุณนิคจำ
ได้ว่ามันมี 1 เบอร์มันมีแต่ลูกอมอ่ะค่ะ
ของ
ทีมที่บ้านๆน่ะนะคนก็ใส่เบอร์เพื่อจะเอา
อันนั้นก็คือ
ครับ
ก็คนก็คงใช่แบบสนุกนะอยากทำบุญใช่มั้ยทำ
บุญช่วยคน
ก็น่าสนใจดีครับขาหนูว่าผู้หญิงเคยไปงาน
การกุศลดับไปไม่เคยเลยพูนิกข์ประเทศไทย
ไม่มีไหมคะมีไหมเพราะเนี่ยจริงๆก็เป็นงาน
แรกที่คุณนี้เคยมึงการกุศลก็เลยไม่รู้ว่า
ในทั่วประเทศไทยอ่ะมันเป็นยังไงคุณนี้คือ
แค่ว่าเหมือนอย่างงานกาชาดเขาจะมีสอยดาว
คุณนี้เอออย่างนั้นแหละเออใช่ค่ะคือแบบไป
แบบว่ามันจะมีเหมือนแบบเนี้ยเดี๋ยวเราคุณ
ค่ะอ่ะ
อันนี้เห็น
เป็นหน้าจอนี้ไหมครับเห็นถ้าเห็นหมดเลย
สมมติอันนี้ครับก็
แสกสอยดาวก็จะเป็นเหมือนต้นไม้ถึงจริงๆ
ไหมที่เป็นต้นไม้แบบให้เรา
บางที่นอนแล้วแต่ว่างานที่ไหนมาจ่ายเค้า
จะมีดาวใช่ไหมคะมีดาวมีดาวคนเล็กชื่อดาว
มันก็จะมีจะมีเบอร์ใช่ไหมเบอร์ 1 เบอร์ 2
ลูกชิ้นทำไมเอาสีเดียวกันล่ะคะ
ลูกพี่เก่งขอเบอร์ 2 เบอร์ 3 เบอร์ 4
อย่างนี้เขาก็จะมีเบอร์อานุชว่าเอาเบอร์
หนึ่งเป็นตุ๊กตาสมัยเป็นตุ๊กตา
[เพลง]
แต่เป็นตุ๊กตานะคะอ่าครูนิก็
สอยดาวออกมาก็จะเป็นคนที่สมมติอันนี้เป็น
คุณนิคละกันคนคิดก็มีไม้อ่ะเขาเมื่อก่อน
นะคะก็จะมีไม้แล้วก็ให้ไปสอยเอาว่าจะเอา
เบอร์อะไร
ทรายค่ะคิดว่า 1 ดาว 1 ดวงก็ประมาณยี่สิบ
บาทนะคะคุณนกคุณอีกใช่ร้อง 20 บาทเพราะ
ว่าของมันจะเล็กๆบางครั้งก่อนจะเป็นแบบ
อัดฝอยดาวได้ปากกาอย่างเงี้ยหาได้ขนม
ก็สนุกสนุกกับคนที่คิดว่าอย่างนี้ครับใน
งานกาชาดก็ก็เหมือนจะเป็นทำบุญหรือเปล่า
ใช่มั้ยส่วนใหญ่เขาก็ไปทำบุญชายค่ะแต่แบบ
ผู้หญิงให้แน่ใจว่าทำบุญอะไรเอ่ยถ้าเป็น
งานสอยดาวแบบนี้มีเคยไปอยู่แต่งานกาชาดใน
ประเทศไทยมันจะประมาณเดือนที่ 4 ร้อนว่า
ที่ไทยตอนไหนก็ร้อน
ใช่แล้วเดือนที่ 4 เป็นเดือนที่ร้อนว่างๆ
ๆๆครับ
ก็คิดว่าที่ไทยก็จะเป็นแบบนั้นมากมึง
เหมือนเก่าจับฉลากใส่ถ้วย
จ่ายค่ะมันก็เป็นเรื่องสนุกๆทูนิคเอามา
เล่าให้นักเรียนฟังนะคะแต่ว่าคิดว่าวัน
นี้หมดเวลาแล้วน้องในวีดีโอนี้
ค่ะเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะ
วีดีโอหน้าเรามาดูกันว่าจะเล่าจะเล่า
เรื่องอะไรให้ฟังจ่ายค่ะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้
ก็ต้องไปแล้วนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกันนะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ
ม.ค